so you were mentioning that you were you
know initial d very well and all that
anime but i'm curious do you know
actually
like any other anime or any other are
you into any anime
you are in an anime podcast yeah okay so
the um
one of the anime podcasts one of the
things that maybe a bit more confident
to reach out to you guys was that i used
to be
massively like into anime a lot hell
yeah
yeah how long ago were we talking okay
so
it's 20 20 now i was in probably
like middle school high school so like
we're talking like 1994
i'd say it was 92 93 94 honestly you're
in high school
i was two years old this is the era of
uh you know
vhs rental tapes and right right of
course just going forward like you know
uh
people you know irc list serves and
stuff like downloading random
getting throttled you know downloading
too much stuff
swapping cds and you know things like
that learning so how did you get anime
back then how did you get how does one
get into anime back then what was what
was like the entry point
oh wow well i mean probably i mean most
people say like oh yeah i saw
uh what what was the actual name from
macross uh
okay so every time i would see and this
sort of
i watched the uh the podcast with um uh
with chris yeah when he talked about
this sort of thing where just every time
you see something from japan
there's just something about it that
just kind of resonated yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you just see like yeah i
i this is my aesthetic i like this
yeah so every time i saw and sometimes
you know you don't realize what it is
and you're like oh
back oh that was actually a japanese
anime right or like even stuff like
inspector gadget which was
you know it was a french all those
french japanese productions back then
like i just
yeah just something about because it was
animated in japan yeah yeah and
slowly slowly it just starts to be like
you see this tape at the
civic video which is my local rental
shop like
what is this crazy looking thing this
rated r18
oh you take it to the candy like
they don't care it's like it's just some
animation here whatever like that yeah
yeah it's like
you know um uh wicked city and oh oh
oh wicked city dude so you so you got
into anime during like the [ __ ]
80s 90s ova bloomberg the manga vhs era
oh my god yeah it was amazing everything
every i just go there and rent that
stuff and it just it just
you know went from there to uh that was
kind of like a golden age in and of
itself
yeah because it was like everything you
could like anime was so brutal back then
everything was devilman crybaby yeah
pretty much you know what i mean like
wicked city ninja scroll
yeah vampire hunter violence jack yeah
[ __ ] like that was just like
so [ __ ] up it was so good cyber city
oido 808 yeah yeah yeah yeah
so i'm actually wearing this is the my
akira shirt that's such a thing
too so this is this is about 20
something years old i just don't know
wow we're here today although again
akira all that sort of stuff it's just
like blows your mind like oh this is so
cool and it was just always
you know enjoyable um any sort of media
you can just get your hands on
uh back then like the uk video game
magazines were very good with that sort
of thing like they
they you know what about that so there
was a from what i could tell there was a
huge like
imports like gray import scene back in
the day for video games so people would
they'd be playing like japanese stuff
all the time these certain video game
magazines they'd feature a lot of
japanese content i do remember like
roughly having some memory of seeing a
lot of japanese
stuff growing up which is why i think
eventually i did get into it because i
always thought like every like you said
every time you see it you're like man
that's really [ __ ] cool
yeah it always just happened to be
japanese stuff that was always the thing
that
like stuck out to me yeah so was it like
a like a nintendo power
but like not a legend in the uk yeah
there are a lot of yeah like
it was called hyper it was called hyper
that sounds familiar yeah it was i'm
pretty sure there's a magazine called
hyper and i've managed to find a big
like download dump of it a while like
every issue scanned i was like
gaming publications in the uk and stuff
like that were huge for a very long time
cv and g or whatever it was called i
can't remember but i remember that there
was
just like everyone had demo discs from
the magazines
i remember those days the ps1 demo discs
that you get with them
we didn't have that yeah and just stuff
would be you know you'd it'd be like
some sort of video game where you'd see
it and it's like you'd find out later
like oh that was actually
like it was like a japanese game yeah
yeah that particular sort of thing right
yeah
so i mean look it and it just it
snowballed from there i didn't have any
friends who were into it in in
my school not nobody not even like maybe
like one
kid from hong kong or like kind of like
dragon ball that
why is it always dragon ball yeah i
don't know so yeah you have like some of
the little cars whatever
yeah and you know it got to the point
where it's things like
going to specialty shops and like
ordering like say i remember i bought
the
uh when evangelion came out like the
movie yeah i ordered the vhs tape
because
it first came out of vhs yeah no
subtitles i wanted the best the highest
quality and i downloaded the script
my original yeah my my original
experience of the ava movie was
sitting there going god you were fans
subbing yourself
you were like live fan sobbing
evangelion that's crazy
oh my god dude i swear i like i feel
that but like this is embarrassing
when i watch [ __ ] like shakespeare
and like the globe theater i couldn't
[ __ ] understand
because they they they talk in like an
older version i don't know what type of
english it's called
speaking english i was like [ __ ]
online like following the story i'm like
oh oh this is that part
i couldn't understand a [ __ ] thing
but obviously yours is a lot more
understandable
same thing but you you get it it's like
but unfortunately
there's that one scene where can i spoil
it or not is it old enough
why haven't you watched ava yeah where
where oscar gets stabbed through the
head and they're ripped apart yeah i
i accidentally read that too early
[Laughter]
and she's like one of my favorites one
of my favorite characters like you know
uh eva gets violently ripped apart i'm
like
and then they all died
i remember feeling it was like two in
the morning i remember feeling sick i
was like oh my god
oh
when i talk about talk about hard-coded
fan subs you know what i mean yeah right
and now we're talking about [ __ ]
[ __ ] hard coded fan subs how about on
paper printed paper bags
like 25 sheets of paper it was it was
about that thing
did they have like translated notes and
everything to like no it was like
it was planned it was pretty good like
it was it was designed
for people to read like to read and
watch right
type said it pretty well yeah it was it
was crazy downloaded off like some
some um you know something like some
weird website so you're like more of an
og anime fan than any of us do we would
we do things like where we'd swap
vhs tapes like you'd what you do is
watch yeah i've heard about i thought
you'd have like your list of all your
content you'd have that like somewhere
and then people you're friends with like
they'd say hey can do
i want that what do you want from mine
and you'd make a copy of the tape and
send it to each other
that sounds so fun